[Musique]
nous sommes devant un tableau de Louis
valtard qui représente le marchand d'art
en broiseevard qui était en briseevard
un réignonné né à Saint-Denis en 1868
mort à Paris en
1939 et c'est un un personnage qui a été
un personnage qui est extrêmement
important dans le monde
artistique entre la fin du 19e siècle et
sa mort en 1939 parce que si je vous dis
Picasso si je vous dis goguin si je vous
dis césane si je vous dis Renoir tout ça
c'est des noms qui sont devenus qui font
partie de la culture générale
aujourd'hui mais sachez que Volard a été
le premier à à faire et il a fait il a
fait redécouvrir l'œuvre de césane en
1895 c'est lui qui a fait la la première
exposition de Picasso en France il y a
un certain nombre d'artistes qui
aujourd'hui font partie d'histoire de
l'art et sont devenus des références in
contontournable de l'histoire de l'art
entre la fin du 19e siècle etbut siècle
et au centre de tout ça personnage
incontournable de cette production
artistique parce qu'il les a soutenu
parce qu'il les a aidé bon il y a eu des
rapports un peu conflictuels aussi avec
ces artistesl mais Volard prend des
risque Volard soutient l'avant-garde
artistique de la fin du 19e siècle et du
début du 20e siècle et dollar va devenir
le marchand de toutes les grandes
collections européennes et américaines
entre la fin du 19e siècle et le début
du 20e siècle ce portrait de de de de
Valta est intéressant parce qu'il
représente Volard relativement jeune
probablement dans sa galerie sa toute
petite Garie qu'il avait ouverte et là
on on on a un portrait qui est qui est
issu justement du courant
impressionniste puisque on a tracé avec
des traits très rapidement le le costume
on a posé on a fait on voit des traits
verts on voit des traits noirs et ce le
le le le le pintte ne s'est pas attaché
à détailler les vêtements il a posé
juste des traits on voit même que la
couleur de la toile ici a servi de fond
c'est qu' la toile n'a pas été peinte et
la couleur de la toile participe à la
couleur du costume et par contre il a
concentré son attention sur le visage
sur la main sur le
[Musique]
livre
fore